what we've been working on for the past
almost year is just kind of like the
training method that I do and it's the
same training method that I use for Kim
it's mostly about eating I mean people
think it's in the exercise but if you're
not eating right consistently then it's
just never gonna happen
you know her diet has like come a long
way and has changed a lot in terms of
just eliminating processed foods and
just getting her to eat real food so if
it comes in a box if it didn't grow off
a tree or the earth didn't give it to
you then just stay away from it fresh
foods unprocessed foods and only water
as for the workouts I would do something
that's mixed so that there's weight
training there's high intensity interval
training and there's steady-state cardio
for now you know I trained him
consistently sometimes I trained her
sisters Khloe and Kourtney
she's even snow chinese-american ELISA I
give her the privilege of working out
with her one time I honestly I just love
her she's also like one of the best
clients that you could ever happen you
know she doesn't cancel she's always
there this is what I'm doing today a lot
of our sessions are at 6 a.m. I wake up
at 4 so we train about five six days a
week it ranges from like an hour to an
hour and a half you do a lot of squats
deadlifts chest press overhead press ton
a ton of sprints pull-ups dips but I
would say that 85% of our training is
weight training you have to put the work
in you have to like you have to be
intense you have to struggle with every
rep and and feel it doesn't mean that
you're gonna be Arnold and get huge you
guys she's trying to kill me officialy
trying to kill me in the beginning you
know I was like sitting on my couch I
gained 70 pounds with my daughter and I
saw this infomercial for insanity which
is a home workout program and I saw
these people's transformations of impact
of all of my food I never cheated only
drink water never missed the workout and
60 days later I was 40 pounds lighter I
decided I wanted to do a bodybuilding
competition in December of 2015 I won
the first place in this figure and in
this physique and that's when Kim
contacted me so she saw my
transformation picture on Instagram she
was like scrolling through Instagram
before o'clock in the morning and she
was like wow this woman she's a mom you
know she lives like a regular life look
at how she changed her life she was
looking for something that was
sustainable you know she didn't want to
just lose weight fast and then you know
gain it again it's a lifestyle I had no
expectations of becoming a celebrity
trainer I'm not thinking oh yeah
a trained Oprah tomorrow I just hope
that you know they get the results of it
that they're looking for and every time
she sees a new muscle growing or new
lines new definition do they see my
muscles they look on her face just makes
me like super excited for her because I
know exactly what that feels like
hamstrings my favorite is the light bar
this
[Music]